every relationship is never a
relationship that you can color with one
color there may be something else there
going on in this case it's about love I
am looking for the Nino and I'm here to
break down a scene from my movie
Suspiria this scene is a Madame Blanc
played by Tilda Swinton tries to educate
Susie Kota Johnson in order to make
better jams so that she can then play
the leading role in the dance fault
[Music]
when you dance the dance of another now
I pose because the scene opens with a
very swift pan the point is that this
was conceived as a long shot and what
happens always with my very beloved
editor Walter Fasano I come to the
editing room with all the expectations
and the ambitions of these long shots
and then he cuts them for me so this was
already a character anyway you make
yourself in the image of its creator you
empty yourself so that her work and live
within you do you understand this is a
scene that happens in a specific room
which is the room of the mirror that you
as you can see for me it was clear that
we had to experience the reflections in
the room without visual effect we
actually shoot them in front of aerial
mirrors and we digitally remove the
camera that's the illusion we created
here but I had many people in trying to
convince me to have the full
CGI thing there and I just didn't want
to do it I know I'm a no person I hate
to lose time you're at a company now you
have to find your right place you have
to decide what is it you want to be for
this company the thing that I like what
I do a space for cinema with my
production designers is that we try to
make it as real as possible in this case
we found this hotel on the top of a hill
in the city of Juarez which was
completely abandoned
and on the left side of the frame you
had a big window overlooking the valley
so this is a wall that we added but the
columns that you see those are part of
the structure of the building everything
else is made by us it's fine the look of
Madame Blanca tilde which is always so
fantastic and I am Julie percenter the
coffee designer we really thought of
many icons in the world of dance in the
20th century and one was of course been
about her long hair but also her
beautiful impaired Imperial attitude
that clearly something that is ominous
controlling that has to deal with the
idea of really making the other do what
you want but at the same time clearly
there is a very magnetic attraction
between these two people and there is a
sort of twisted love happening there I
wanna be this company's hands I think
this moment is when really the bond
deceit between the two women
Suzie balances the hand and you let her
discover in the narrative of the movie
why the hand but I would say the hands
comes with the idea that a gesture can
dictate an action for somebody I would
like not to say more because I would be
aspired to something quite disturbing
hi Takata was incredible in the way she
committed to make sure that her Suzy
Bunyan was a real dancer on screen she
spent time dancing when she was a
teenager we both agreed that the dance
had to be a big commitment so she
started doing physical reactor size and
training with a trainer in New York way
before the movie even started
pre-production here is a moment that of
transition that is very important where
all the witches are discussing about
their future they feel they are in peril
of being extinguished this scene was in
the script written by the great Dave
cationic happening 25 minutes earlier
than what is now in the movie in
combining this scene with the cotton
Tilda to feel a new energy in the
meeting with a girl that comes from us
outside which was greater to show a
moment of progression and a moment of
regression together tied and then
something happens after after this scene
this is very telling of what I like
about cinema she jumps and go up in the
air finally thanks to the editing there
is no special effect no visual effect no
CGI I believe we pull off pretty well
the magic that is happening in that
moment that Madame Blanc make her jump
up and it's a Josh a question of
performance and framing and editing and
that makes me very happy
sometimes I only need to be told twice
and I like the way she smirks here thank
you for watching this scene breakdown
run to the theaters November the second
wide release of Suspiria and of course
get your tickets on Fandango
[Music]
[Music]